now for our daily cancellation uh we
have
up to bat here so to speak ryan cooper
he's a correspondent for
the publication of the week and he was
reacting to an article in the wall
street journal an article that
uh complains that pickup trucks are too
big these days
because someone decided to write an
entire article
around the kind of banal observation you
make when you've been in a car for seven
hours with somebody
and there's nothing left to talk about
so you're just driving along and you
turn to them and say
well these pickup trucks are really big
you notice that really big these days
yeah yeah they are
yeah but they're really big in fact
all kinds of cars are big these days
yeah
uh riveting conversation as always in
the cars but
ryan's observation though is not quite
that banal in fact it's actually pretty
fascinating this is what he says
sales of mega pickups which have
basically been deliberately designed to
intimidate and kill pedestrians
are booming it's one thing to say that
they're too big it's another thing to
say they're deliberately designed
to kill pedestrians now
uh well no no sorry he didn't say
delivery said basically
deliberately designed and can i just say
for the record
as we're doing this in fact i'm going to
cancel the word basically too because
the word basically is not as it is so
often used
in escape hatch allowing you to make
wildly inaccurate claims okay
people throw the word basically into a
sentence thinking that
they can then veer off into fantasyland
and basically is this magical
incantation that makes their fantasy
into a reality
so this happens all the time especially
in arguments i mean we've all it's very
common these days where you say
something like um
well i think that we we spend too much
on entitlements
entitlement programs in this country and
the person responds oh
oh so you're basically saying that we
should round up all the poor people and
throw them into the sea
isn't it that's that's basically what
you're saying
no that's not what i'm basically saying
at all in fact it's uh
what i'm basically saying is what i said
because it's a pretty basic
concept so i i said what i said and
that's really all that i said
as for the claim that ryan is making
here i hope i don't have to spend too
much time
debunking it um you know uh
i i i don't know if i need to present
like sources and evidence to to debunk
the claim
that pickup trucks are designed with the
intention of killing pedestrians
um i guess he imagines a scenario where
people go to the dealership
like the ford dealership and say yeah
i'm looking for a pickup truck with a
good towing capacity
a long bed um oh and the ability to
pulverize five old ladies at a time
while they're crossing the street you
have anything for that oh right this way
sir yeah we have
we have a section just for that right
over here um that's what he imagines
let me put his mind to rest
ryan don't worry um
i myself have have lived in many small
towns and rural type areas
i've been around quite a lot of pickup
trucks i don't drive one myself
as i said before i drive a suburban
because i have
four kids as well um
and but i've been around them quite a
bit and i i can tell you that they are
not designed to kill you so you can calm
down
city boy you uh no one's gonna run you
over while you're sitting at your cafe
eating french pancakes or whatever the
hell you're doing
pickup trucks are not designed for that
they're designed very simply to carry
machine guns
really big machine guns and that's how
pickup drivers kill pedestrians
with machine guns okay and it's it's
it's a much
quicker death you know less less painful
so just stop being so paranoid and stop
complaining also
all right and you're canceled
um
[Music]
there we go hopefully hopefully i i
thought we could we could end on a
positive note there just a word of
encouragement for our friend uh ryan
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content